[موسيقى]
المركز التجاري الصغير عبارة عن دمية يبلغ ارتفاعها 12 قدمًا
تمثل فتاة سورية تبلغ من العمر 10 سنوات ، حيث يقف
محرك العرائس على ركائز متينة ، وهناك ثلاث
دمى تعمل أو واحدة في الداخل وواحدة
على كل ذراع
[موسيقى] ،
إنه أمر مثير بالنسبة لي لأنني في الأساس
أصبحت أميركيًا  أعرف ، وأنا
أسترالية إيرانية تركية ، كما تعلمون ،
لدي خلفية مختلطة وقد
عشت في أوروبا وكنت لاجئًا في جميع
أنحاء العالم ، يمثل عمر أم
أقليات من الناس من الثقافة وكيف
اجتمع الجميع معًا وكان ذلك
رائعًا.  من الجيد أيضًا أن
يجتمع الجميع معًا بغض النظر عن ما يدعمها فقط
[موسيقى]
مراكز التسوق الصغيرة للدمى التي تم إنشاؤها من خلال فرصة جيدة
في الدمى اليدوية
لتمثيل نموذج اللاجئ
الذي يتجول.
إنها
تمثل حقًا جميع الأطفال
وجميع المهاجرين واللاجئين
رسالة [موسيقى] أجنبية إلى العالم هي لا تنسونا
[موسيقى]